our favorite show Fox & Friends hosted
by Steve Doocy Ainsley Earhardt and
Brian Kilmeade it's always good for a
laugh and after the Sutherland Springs
Texas mass shooting they came up with I
guess they were looking for some kind of
silver lining or something about that
horrible terrorist act of shooting that
and what they found was that the people
at the church who were shot were doing
the right thing because they were close
to Jesus at the time that they got got
shot that's I guess what they're saying
is if you're going to be shot being at
church is a good thing here's the clip
from Fox & Friends
governor you know we've been reporting
this shouldn't happen in a church but I
was downstairs talking with some people
that work here that we all talk about
our faith and we share the same beliefs
we were saying there's no other place we
would want to go and that other than
church because I'm they're asking for
forgiveness I feel very close to Christ
when I'm there so I'm trying to look at
some positives here and know that those
people are with the Lord now and
experiencing eternity and and no more
suffering no more sadness anymore right
so there's that that's a clip not from
Pat Robertson's 700 club show ok that's
from Fox News one of the three major
cable news stations in the country and
it is nauseating if I had to get first
first of all let's talk about the
specifics right if I had to get shot
somewhere I'd want to be shot at a
hospital right but that assumes that
language is the language when we say
people are going to be shot you're
already assuming that right that there's
not even a possibility of maybe people
not being shot in mass shootings hey
it's America people are going to be shot
the conversation is where would we
rather be when we get shot but if you
really want to go down this path of
since they were in church and shot
they're now living suffering free
eternities in heaven with Jesus Christ
why did God allow
church-going Christians to be shot in
the first place right why would God do
that
oh well God works in mysterious ways
that is the cop-out to end all cop outs
from people like Ainsley Earhardt
who was downstairs talking to other Fox
News staffers who share her faith
real question is not did you go to
heaven faster if you're shot dead in a
church
it's where was God during the shooting
if not in a Christian Church on a Sunday
morning
Fox News is basically like a half step
away from asking for donations so that
they can spread the gospel of Jesus
Christ at this point she talks about
wanting to find something positive in
the mass shooting it's a mass shooting
why would there be anything positive
with the only positive thing I can think
of is that there are some people who
didn't die but were merely injured
because the guy had only semi-automatic
weapons instead of fully automatic
weapons right that's the only very
concocted forced silver lining that I
can find here not that at least when
you're shot in church you're close to
Jesus and the scariest part of this you
were telling me this Pat I guess the New
York Times wrote that Fox and Friends in
a sense is like the most powerful show
we're very powerful because Trump
watches it on a regular basis that's the
scariest thing I can think of very scary
is he watching this every day do we know
just about I would imagine right I think
sideshow they I'm guessing that in his
propaganda file because this program
doesn't it start at like 4:00 or 5:00 in
the morning it's on very very early I'm
guessing that in Trump's 9:30 a.m.
propaganda file or 9:00 a.m. he gets
lots of screenshots from Fox & Friends
I wonder if this means he's not watching
Morning Joe anymore oh he's totally off
Morning Joe because Mika was bleeding
badly
from a face lift from a face lift and
what was the other Joe crazy joe
scarborough not happy with and what else
there no he's completely off that show
starts really early as well i think we
stopped this early i don't even know who
watches these programs although I read
on the internet of people that get up
extremely early I have I have read about
them I'm not totally unfamiliar with
that so anyway there it is Fox News
indistinguishable not from a parody but
from the 700 club with Pat Robertson now
saying if you're gonna get shot a church
is the place because you will be close
to Jesus Christ and I guess that'll
shorten your commute into heaven or
something I don't I don't even know what
she's talking about